Je rêve !
Il y a une faute !
Ne bougez pas… Je vais arranger ça !
Voilà ! C’est mieux…
Mais qu’est ce qu’il y a là-dedans ?
Allez ! On efface tout
et on recommence depuis le début...
dans l’atelier !
Commençons par l’encre.
Elle est essentiellement constituée d’eau, dans laquelle on a ajouté un pigment pour lui donner de la couleur.
En l’occurrence, un pigment bleu.
Alors des pigments, il en existe
de toutes les couleurs ou presque.
En général, ils se présentent sous forme de poudre.
Aujourd’hui, la plupart est fabriqué
à partir de produits dérivés du pétrole
mais à l’origine les fabricants de couleur
utilisaient des matières premières naturelles.
Il y a par exemple le noir de fumée,
utilisé pour fabriquer de l’encre de Chine,
obtenu en broyant du charbon de bois.
Les ocres, qui proviennent
de terres naturellement colorées.
Le bleu outremer est obtenu en broyant du lapis-lazuli,
une pierre précieuse.
A l’époque, ce pigment valait plus cher que l’or.
Parfois les coloristes ont de drôles d’idées.
Ils utilisent des matières premières,
auxquelles je suis sûr, vous n’auriez pas pensé.
Le rouge carmin, par exemple,
est obtenu en broyant des insectes :
des cochenilles.
Et le jaune indien à partir d’un produit fourni par la vache...
son urine !
Meuh !
L’encre bleue effaçable est fabriquée à partir
d’un pigment qu’on appelle le bleu d’aniline.
Cette molécule a été mise au point au XIXe siècle.
Sa couleur est due à la façon
dont elle réagit avec la lumière.
Petit éclairage !
La lumière émise par le Soleil,
vous le savez peut-être déjà,
est constituée d’un large spectre de couleurs
les fameuses couleurs de l’arc-en-ciel.
Souvenez-vous, je vous en ai parlé
lorsque j’ai fabriqué un arc-en-ciel dans le jardin.
Lorsqu’elle arrive sur la molécule
qui compose le pigment bleu,
la lumière est entièrement absorbée…
À l’exception du bleu qui est renvoyé vers nos yeux.
Voilà pourquoi cette encre nous apparaît bleue !
Pour les encres rouges ou vertes,
le principe est exactement le même,
sauf que les pigments renvoient le rouge
ou le vert contenu dans le spectre.
Je sais ! Je vous en fais voir de toutes les couleurs.
Et ça ne nous dit toujours pas comment
l’effaceur fait disparaître l’encre bleue.
J’y viens…
L’encre bleue, on l’a dit,
est essentiellement constituée d’eau,
des molécules H2O et des pigments.
L’eau permet en fait de transporter les pigments.
Une fois sur le papier, elle s’évapore.
Les pigments, eux, restent accrochés
aux fibres du papier et se lient avec elles.
Et oui ! En principe, on attend d’une encre
qu’elle s’imprime bien
et qu’elle soit visible pour délivrer
correctement le message !
Le revers de la médaille,
c’est qu’une fois déposée sur le papier,
l’encre ne peut plus être retirée.
Impossible de briser les liens qui se sont établis
entre les molécules qui constituent
le pigment et celles du papier.
C’est dire si la tâche est rude pour l’effaceur…
Facile…
Mais il a une botte secrète… Suivez-moi !
Sa botte secrète, c’est le produit qu’il contient :
du bisulfite de sodium et de l’eau.
Quand ils entrent en contact avec l’encre,
une réaction chimique se produit.
L’aniline ne disparaît pas mais sa structure change.
Du coup, elle ne réagit plus
de la même manière à la lumière.
Désormais, toutes les couleurs la traversent
et atteignent le papier.
L’aniline devient invisible et c’est le blanc
du papier qui est renvoyé vers nos yeux.
Tenez, je vais vous montrer quelque chose.
Jusqu’à présent j’ai effacé des lettres.
Mais on peut aussi rendre visible
un message qui ne l’était pas.
Un message secret par exemple.
Durant les deux dernières guerres,
c’était le grand jeu des espions.
Tenez ! Vous voyez cette feuille ?
Elle a l’air parfaitement vierge
et pourtant elle porte un message.
On ne le voit pas parce que je l’ai écrit
avec du jus de citron.
Pour le rendre visible,
il suffit de passer la feuille
au-dessus de la flamme d’une bougie.
Attention ! Comme on ne joue pas avec le feu,
cette expérience nécessite
impérativement la présence d’un adulte.
Allez ! C’est parti…
Et voilà !
En fait, au contact de la chaleur
les sucres contenus dans le jus de citron caramélisent
et le message apparaît.
Alors je sais… C’est la fin de cette vidéo !
Mais pas la peine de vous faire un sang d’encre…
On se retrouve dans une quinzaine de jours
et d’ici là : bonne rentrée !
Le noir de fumée qui est utilisé
pour faire de l'encre d'échine
La plupart se présentent....
Ooooh ! Pfffff....
La plupart, la plupart !
Il y a un truc qui va pas !
Je suis en train de me demander
Parce que si on a du vent tout à l'heure,
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas que je mette un foulard ?